it is October 1st 2022 so it is time for
another monthly update video in which
we'll talk about what went on in
September that you might have missed and
want to check out and what we've got
coming up in October and this is a big
month
I've I we I always like to begin by
talking about three big things so big
thing number one is one of the biggest
things of the year if you're interested
in stoicism or practical philosophy and
that is the stoicon conference coming up
online on October 29th look down below
and you'll see a link to get tickets or
find out more big thing number two is
also stoic related it also happens near
the end of the month and it is stoic
week and let me say too that stoicon and
stoic week 10-year anniversary for both
of them big thing number three is just
about me not stoicism or world events or
stuff like that I'm going to be doing
some YouTube shorts I did one of them to
get some ideas about what I might do I
got a lot of really helpful feedback
from people so look forward to those
rolling filling out this month I can't
promise to do one every day but we'll
see what we can actually get
accomplished
so September was quite a month I had a
few illnesses that I had to deal with
and of course classes are in full swing
and I'm teaching full load of classes
for Milwaukee Institute of Art and
Design and Marquette University
you may have seen some of the new videos
that I I shot for the Marquette
University classes I have two sections
of a class it's an upper level core
class that is called service of faith
and promotion of Justice supposed to be
a
problem-centered class so I picked the
problem of anger and my students are
learning an awful lot about anger how
it's caused how to evaluate it even some
techniques for dealing with anger and
um yeah what else well we had our normal
AMA and worlds of speculative fiction we
did JG Ballard who people have been
asking about for a very long time
um we shot a wisdom for Life episode
rather we recorded it and also shot
video at the same time so that was on
rhetoric and you know I did my usual
Hegel meetings and philosophy chat and
all of that sort of stuff I've taken on
some new clients as well if people keep
coming to me for philosophical
counseling or tutorials or stuff along
those lines and you know I'm happy to do
it it is a lot of people who I'm I'm in
contact with and then video work what
did I do as to videos well uh quite a
few core concept videos and the core
concept videos have indeed been on the
topic of anger so we started out well
actually finished up I think we started
them let the the previous month with uh
core concept videos on Aristotle's
rhetoric book two and his discussion of
anger and calmness there we also did
some on Audrey Lords the uses of anger
and then I took a little bit of a detour
getting some class videos ready for a
different class uh lucretiuses on the
nature of things I think people kind of
like that Epicurean stuff and then I
came back to anger with the Bishop
Joseph Butler sermon eight stuff
discussing all sorts of aspects of anger
and uh what else I managed to get a
review video done on carniades uh he has
a YouTube channel you may be familiar
with him he also has a recent book out
or all lives equal and there's a very
long subtitle which we won't go into
um I also did
um a Sadler's stories about summer jobs
that I had had one year I did a uh
caption contest video about a messy
bookshelf and floor and I did a first
short where I asked people what do you
think I can do with with shorts for
philosophy and I got a lot of really
useful feedback that I've been mauling
over and and thinking about
um and podcast episodes I I released
quite a few on Aristotle Nick and McCann
ethics book six that I had started
before and then we went through Renee
Descartes uh discourse on method uh you
know I thought that I'd actually
produced podcast episodes on that and I
needed them for my class that I'm
teaching for Milwaukee Institute of Art
and Design and so then I I checked and
nope they weren't there so I had to I
had to get those done and then I've been
doing stuff on Epictetus I have all
these core concept videos on Epictetus
from when I actually produced an online
course on him and
um yeah what I've been doing is
um converting those into podcast
episodes so releasing quite a few of
those some of them I have early release
to my patreon supporters if that's
something you're interested in there's a
link below for for patreon as well
um so that I think that's pretty much it
for September it's been a very busy
month uh I didn't get as much
accomplished as I would have liked but
isn't that the way it always goes
all right what do we have coming up in
October well next Saturday the 8th at
noon we'll have our usual AMA that's
asked me anything sessions so if you've
got questions for me that's a great time
and place to ask them make sure that you
get them in early in the session because
I tend to get too many to successfully
answer in the hour and a half that I
allot to it then also on on the 8th at 2
p.m I will be having my philosophy chat
for patreon supporters again if that
interests you you can find the link to
become a supporter Below on the 12th
which is a Wednesday at 5 00 p.m all
these are Central Time by the way uh
we'll have our Hegel monthly you know q
a discussion to talk about Hegel German
idealism philosophy in general that's
always a good time that's video
conferencing with me and then on the
15th a Saturday we'll be having starting
at noon Central Time the next World's a
speculative fiction it's going to be on
Philip K dick and it's going to be about
Androids and humans so we're looking at
of course Android's Dream of Electric
Sheep and we'll talk a little bit about
the movie Blade Runner and how it's
different from uh to Android's Dream of
Electric Sheep and what dick actually
thought about it we're also going to
talk about a book yeah a novel called
the similacra and another one called we
can build you and we'll see if we can
get to the short story The Imposter
which was turned into a movie long after
dick died with Gary Sinise I believe is
just called imposter and we're going to
look at some stuff from the exegesis as
well and from several essays that he
wrote about humans and Androids so that
is going to be a lot of fun begins at
noon with a video premiere that runs
about 90 100 minutes and then we go into
a video conferencing session after that
on the 19th if you're here in the
Milwaukee area I'm going to be at
Marquette University the philosophy
department has invited me to give a talk
about stoicism and virtue and how the
stoic conception of virtue has some
weird paradoxes about it that not even
all the stoics except and that is going
to be in the
midwest
seminar in ancient and medieval
philosophy it will be recorded and it'll
be held on campus details about that
will be coming out soon you can find
them in my Facebook or other social
media that'll be at 3 30 p.m and then on
the 27th at 6 00 PM we'll have our
Milwaukee stoic fellowship meeting and
we'll probably be talking about the next
big thing that's coming up right after
that on the 29th on Saturday I will be
emceeing for stoicon 2020
um and it's you know we've got a great
lineup of a lot of very interesting
speakers and panelists and Chris Gill is
going to be giving the keynote address
which is really quite wonderful and so
you you know you don't want to miss that
you can get a ticket for any donation
amount and spend the whole day learning
about stoicism from some of the best
contemporary authors and presenters on
the topic so I hope you'll you'll join
me for that
um you know classes like I mentioned
they're in full swing October is kind of
a crunch month we do have a very short
spring break that'll give us like a
couple days off but I'll be spending
those days doing work and you know stuff
along those lines but the students all
enjoy having a few days off I I would
imagine
a lot of other stuff going on in terms
of clients I'm going to try to get back
to the gym I haven't been to the gym for
over a month and I'm kind of craving
that but I've just been too busy lately
video work so I've got more core concept
videos to shoot on Joseph Butler now on
sermon nine which has to do with
forgiveness but also has to do with
anger I'll be shooting some on Thomas
Aquinas some of the relevant passages
and sections about anger from the
somatea logiai I'm hoping to shoot some
videos on locktancius's on the anger of
God we'll see if I get to that that
might be a little overly ambitious but I
do need to shoot some core concept
videos pretty soon on Mary
woolstonecraft uh because I'm teaching
her in several different classes this
faster as I typically do and when I'm
introducing things I'm a big fan of
woolstone craft and I I want to shoot
some core concept videos on that I'm
going to do some more book reviews this
month now that I've got a little bit of
wind in my sails you could say and I I
did get one half hour Hegel video done
which I released to patreon supporters
I'll be releasing that to the public
this month and shooting some more half
hour Hegel videos we're getting really
close to the end of the religion section
and I think I'm if I really bust my ass
I might be able to get that section done
this month wouldn't that be cool I'll
probably shoot some personal videos as
well and more Sadler stories
um some you know caption we'll have a
caption contest I'll probably do another
light haul maybe another saddlers asides
and digressions and we'll see what else
uh tickles my fancy so to speak about
what I what I want to produce and of
course there's going to be plenty of
have shorts coming up so if you you know
want things that are a little thought
provoking and probably not long enough
because they only can be a minute those
might be for you
podcast work
so I've still got a lot more Epictetus
stuff to do I'm hoping to get through
all of that in the next week or so maybe
two weeks and then I'm going to go back
to the schopenhauer videos that I shot
this summer and released then and start
making core concept videos out of those
if I have enough time then maybe I'll
start on the Aristotle rhetoric book two
material but we'll see how it goes you
know there's an awful lot going on it's
a very busy month thank thank goodness
that it has 31 days because man do I
have to get a lot done during that month
so I hope it's a great month ahead for
you I hope you can join us for stoicon
and stoic week and perhaps some of the
other online events that we've got going
up the AMA the uh worlds of speculative
fiction focused on one of my favorite
authors Philip K dick and yeah I'm hope
to see all of you in The Ether and have
a great month ahead